can you think of a moment let's say the
first five years of you living in LA
that helped shape your career like what
I know you talked about you had made
inroads or you unbeknownst to you that
someone that you used to work with
remembered you fondly and was was
handing out your picture but in another
story maybe that liked you you weren't
expecting and it was the first five
years and it kind of changed things for
you well I know that something happened
in the first five years that reinforced
my ethic and my sense of integrity in
this town and it was when a very
well-known personality had taken a shine
to me and knew that I was looking for an
apartment and offered to set me up in an
apartment no strings attached and well I
happen to know it looked something about
strings I refused I mean I graciously
refused but I mean and I met the person
at the apartment to see what it was like
and I took a girl friend along with me
just in case and it was beautiful and it
would have been wonderful but I would
have been bought in some way and you
know it didn't so I still by saying no
thank you I still needed to find an
apartment but the the the power that I
felt in once again counting on myself
I'd like to pay my own rent and buy my
own groceries thank you very much
because that leaves me my own woman and
that was really empowering when I shared
that story with some other people long
ago they were are you crazy
you could have taken it no it wouldn't
have it would have compromised me in my
world of morality it would have been the
wrong thing to do and so I didn't do it
and and again I had to still find
another apartment but when you believe
in yourself and you take a chance things
come and and it came so that more than
because honestly maintaining your
integrity and your your sense of
self-worth is the most important tool
that you have here absolutely the most
important and it goes back to many other
things that we've talked about because
if you have faith in yourself and you
know who you are in the world it doesn't
matter what anyone else says or does
because you know who you are and often
the people who come from the smaller
towns have even a better sense of who
they are because they grew up in a much
less superficial world where hard work
and and values were valued you know so
to me that's the your state of mind and
your sense of self-worth are the most
important things that you can have and
so that was a real an opportunity for me
to you know put up or shut up
this is my you know this is either what
I believe or it's not what I believe and
here's an opera an easy way to it would
have been easy would have been very easy
to just take that opportunity but I
didn't this this is the way you go
forward in my estimation yeah that's a
real elephant in the room in terms of
the entertainment industry and it
happens to men too of course it does and
and it can happen from other men or
other women absolutely but I think it's
it's hard especially for a younger
person to that maybe then somehow feels
very special because this person has
chosen them right and it's hard for them
to see want to be chosen that's why we
come to Hollywood choose me see me you
know yes right and they come on
temptation right in power and I've known
people on both sides of the coin and
have gone the way of
being taken care of and there are
implications and I think we don't
totally realize that right and then if
you got what you got
did you get it or was it or was it just
given to you because of something that
you bartered with you know and and that
that's the other thing I say to about
you know everybody most everybody loves
to have a good time sexually so by
someone I was speaking at at college at
one point in this one came about and I
said look if you think you would have
fun and dead with this person
have sex with them for that reason alone
but do not think for one moment that you
are going to get something out of it
other than fun because you no matter
what sex you are no matter who's
propositioned you you have something
that that person can get anywhere else
and they if they're a person who says
they have a job for you or some other
way of elevating you has something that
only a handful of people have to give
you have nothing to bargain with but if
you think you might have a good romp go
ahead but don't expect anything out of
it you know and that also leaves you in
power of your own life because you made
the choice not because something was
dangled before you but because you
decided you would like to do it because
it would be fun not to get something
right and I think - there's this whole
Scarlet Letter thing where oh yeah she
did this and and uh sometimes I can't
even I mean it just feels like it's a
made-up story
and that's that's the ultimate putting
the Scarlet Letter on someone well right
this person got this because of this
right and half the time it's not even
true and spoken out of jealousy like
like you've you mentioned before yeah
right and it could be that the other
person actually did that and they feel
you know but it's such an interesting
thing that that goes around this and
it's not openly talked about right but
it exists and yeah I I agree with what
you're saying I think if you if it's not
about any type of barter trade agreement
right then
then that's your personal choice but
it's a tough thing and surviving the
gossip of this person did that for this
is a very toxic thing then right you
don't want that no again I don't want
that on me no get rid of that remaining
upbeat and finding hobbies right living
your life living your life live your
life everyday try to do something every
day that has nothing at all to do with
show business
you